good afternoon my name is Karl Whitney
I'm a lieutenant at the garden drill
Police Department I'm the public
information officer we're here today to
do a press conference to talk about the
heinous crimes that happened here in
Garden Grove and Santa Ana yesterday
afternoon took place between 409 p.m.
and culminated with the arrest of the
suspect at 6:27 p.m. so to give the
order of operations what's gonna be
happening right now I'm gonna do the
introductions of EMC in this I'll be
introducing the people behind me
who's going to come up and speak so our
Chief of Police is Tom DeRay be ARP our
city manager Scott Stiles will be
speaking today Mayor Steve Jones will be
also speaking today the members of our
city councilor are all behind me right
now in support we have chief de Valentin
from Santa Fe dv8 al en TI n from the
Orange County District Attorney's Office
we have Paul Walters and Shawn Nelson
here to support us so we'll go through
the different speakers our chief will
speak followed by our mayor followed by
our city manager then I'll come back and
do a recap of where we're at with the
investigation what I plan on doing is
releasing some video after the press
conference to show one of the attacks at
one of the businesses to show how
violent this offender was and then we'll
open it up for some questions after that
so right now when I introduce Tom Chief
Tom DeLay from the Garden Grove police
department
good afternoon first and foremost I want
to express our deepest condolences to
the families of the victims of
yesterday's traumatic event last night
the communities of Garden Grove and
Santa Ana were preyed upon by violent
individual who had no remorse or care
for the safety of anyone other than
himself as the violent acts continued
the Garden Grove police department
deployed all personnel to the area we
activated elements of our SWAT team that
specialized in the apprehension of
dangerous and violent suspects
undercover detectives located the
suspect vehicle in front of the 7-eleven
which was located at Harbor and first
Street in the city of Santa Ana as the
SWAT team and undercover investigators
began to converge in the parking lot the
suspect exited the 7-eleven armed with a
handgun and a large knife as officers
began to give commands the suspect
quickly dropped the weapons and
surrendered to officers it is my belief
that the Garden Grove police officers
response and apprehension of this
individual saved the lives of many other
community members
I would like to command the Garden Road
Police Department for their quick
you
suspect continued his rampage he could
have injured or killed many other
innocent people in addition I would like
to thank our local and federal law
enforcement partners for their support
and assistance during this tragic event
they were quick to offer any resources
that were needed by our department this
suspect is identified as Zachary
Castaneda who has been identified as a
documented gang member
this person should have been in prison
and not allowed to be in our community
committing these violent acts based upon
his prior arrest record he is a violent
individual who should have never been
considered for early release based upon
assembly bill 109 as a police chief
I implore our policy makers to
reevaluate their policies on criminal
justice the pendulum has swung so far
that it is increasingly difficult to
keep our community safe from the rise in
violent crime California law enforcement
agencies have been crippled by assembly
bill 109 and offenders are not being
held accountable for their crimes our
community becomes vulnerable when these
criminals are released back into society
and are able to commit further acts of
violence again our thoughts and prayers
are with the families of the victims of
this violent act
right now if you introduce our mayor for
Garden Grove Steve Jones safety words
thank you and good afternoon everyone as
you can imagine these last couple days
have been very difficult for our city
there have been tireless efforts to
bring this incident to a quick and safe
conclusion which thankfully has occurred
the loss of life is a tragedy in any
community and on behalf of the entire
Garden Grove City Council joined with me
today I would like to first express our
deepest condolences to the families and
loved ones of the innocent victims that
were affected by these atrocious acts
these are the kind of incidents that you
never want to see happen in your city
but the reality is they could happen
anywhere anytime we have to be thankful
in terms of how the danger to our
community was minimized due to the
outstanding work of the Garden Grove in
Santa Ana Police Department's working
together public safety professionals
take an oath to protect and serve the
community and oftentimes that means
putting their own lives on the line so
we thank them for their courage despite
being one of the largest cities in
Orange County we have a very close-knit
community that supports each other and
deeply supports the efforts of our
Police Department thank you again for
coming out today
and thank you to the community of Garden
Grove for their ongoing support
Thank You Merrick City Council now I'd
like to introduce our city manager Scott
Stiles would like to say a few words
Thank You lieutenant
I just want to reiterate the comments
from the chief and the mayor that our
greatest condolences go out to the
victims and their families these last
few days have been very difficult for
our community it's been a struggle
trying to understand the destruction and
mayhem that has been caused we have such
a great community here crime in general
is down in Garden Grove that's due to
the phenomenal partnerships between the
community and our Police Department
random acts of violence such as what
we're responding to yesterday do great
damage to all the good work that's that
we're involved in that's also why as a
city we will continue to listen and and
engage with our community for the sake
of Public Safety those priorities will
always be of critical importance to us I
want to thank chief DeRay all the men
and women of the Garden Grove police
department and our garden girl Fire and
EMS personnel who responded so quickly
to these random acts of violence special
special thanks to our undercover
officers who spotted and apprehended the
suspect in Santa Ana without a doubt
other people would have been at risk but
for their actions do you think you can
stand on your own during situations like
this but it should be noted that we have
had many offers offers of Public Safety
assistance from our surrounding
jurisdictions and agencies that have
reached out to us as the chief indicated
those offers of mutual aid have been and
aren't critical to this situation and we
thank them for that
thank you sir
now just to recap where we're at right
now I'm gonna go over the timeline and
what happened yesterday our first call
to the police department happened at 409
p.m. in the afternoon we received a call
of a residential burglary that happened
at 1 to 6 1 2 jinja's in Garden Grove
this turned out to be our victims from
our homicide that called to report the
burglary they arrived home found their
apartment had been broken into but they
had no suspect information so the call
went into a report holding community how
an officer could be dispatched to handle
the report as that call was holding at
4:23 p.m. we received a call of an armed
robbery in progress at a bakery looking
at 13 0 40 Chapman Avenue in the City of
Garden Grove a male later described as
mr. Castaneda went into the business and
he threatened the clerk with either a
gun or a knife and took cash the suspect
fled that location and returned to his
home at the apartment complex where the
homicide took place on jinja's at one
261 - we believe what happened was the
two victims that had been victimized
during the residential burglary
confronted the suspect as he returned
because they lived in the Jason
apartments an altercation occurred
between our suspect and our two victims
and our two victims were ultimately
stabbed and succumbed to their injuries
at the apartment complex we received a
call right on scene and found both
victims down in front of the apartment
one on the balcony one inside the
apartment one victim was transported to
UCI hospital where he died from his
injuries after the homicide we had the
robbery happen we had the homicide going
on we received a phone call back to our
communication center at 5:30 9:00 p.m.
about another armed robbery matching the
same suspect description this robbery
occurred at the cash and Ward business
located at 1 to 8:45 Chapman our suspect
went into that business threatened the
clerk with a knife and took cash and
fled the scene so now we have two
robberies and we had the double homicide
half
that's draining our resources here in
Garden Grove at 6:06 p.m. another armed
robbery happened at best one insurance
this was a savage attack I'm going to
release this video later on where it
shows the victim a 54 year old employee
inside the business was doing her daily
operations of her business sitting at
her desk feeling safe inside of business
nobody expects to go to an insurance
company to be attacked and almost killed
at the time our suspect walks into the
business confronts the female victim and
without provocation he stabs her
multiple times I'll release this video
after this press conference today after
that stabbing happened there was a check
cashing business in the back of the same
insurance company that female victim
threw cash at the suspect he took the
cash and fled the business after that
attempted murder and robbery
we received another phone call at 6:09
p.m. from a person reporting a stabbing
that happened at the Chevron station
which is near Harbor and banner and
Garden Grove just north of the 22
freeway our 44 year old male Hispanic
victim was pumping gas our suspect was
also getting gassed the same location
sometime during this altercation our
suspect produced two large machete
knives attacked our guy who was pumping
gas with into his truck nearly severing
his nose off and stabbing in the back
our suspect at that time after he
attacked this guy savagely returned to
his vehicle finished pumping gas filled
off his tank and then he drove off south
on Harbor Boulevard Courts of City Santa
Ana at this time we're making radio
announcements across the orange county
we're asking for assistance from other
agencies to be on the lookout for this
suspect our undercover detectives who
were here at the station suited up put
their best on and went out hunting for
this individual we had no indication
where this guy was going to go but our
detectives were on spot and went looking
for this suspect a short time later our
detectives found our suspect vehicle at
the 7-eleven at Harbor and first Street
in the city of Santa Ana within a minute
of looking the vehicle our suspect
came out of the shtetl Evans store armed
with a handgun and
large knife our detectives drew their
weapons onto the suspect ordered him to
drop his weapons he complied he threw
the gun down threw the knife down he was
taken into custody at that same time
customers came out of the set Levin the
store said that the security guard
inside had been stabbed and needed help
our officers diverted into the start
started life-saving measures on this
individual started doing CPR but
unfortunately the security guards later
died at the hospital we learned that the
security guard inside the business was
followed by the suspect was attacked
from behind with a large knife dropping
the security guard to the floor after he
was stabbed numerous times our suspect
used his large knife and cut the weapon
got the gun off the security guards gun
belt that's the gun he walked out of the
store with if not for our undercover
officers stopping this individual coming
up armed with a handgun and knives there
would have been more lost life but loss
of life in the city of Garden Grove or
Santa Ana after this we learned that at
the subway across the street from the
7-eleven we learned that there was
another homicide where an innocent
victim was attacked by the same suspect
so what we have right now for needless
homicides happened here in Garden Grove
and Santa Ana the flags behind me are at
half-staff that's for the needless
violence that's happening across the
United States this violence has to stop
and we're here in a cooperated effort
together to try and stop this violence
in Garden Grove
so our detectives our officers our City
Council our lawmakers behind us are all
together to stop this needless violence
in Orange County so we appreciate all
the support from the community and we
want to make sure this violence stops
what's going to happen from here on out
it's going to take another 48 just 72
hours for us to finish our investigation
we're collecting evidence at all the
different crime scenes there's eight
different crime scenes that's gonna take
time to process as evidence once we have
our case put together the Orange County
District Attorney's Office is going to
file charges on our suspect is going to
be arraigned tomorrow at this point we
don't have any other victims we have the
four victims from the homicide the
robbery suspects
and we're still collecting evidence
right now again the video from the
attack at the location of the insurance
business will be released later today
all right now when I open up the any
questions and I'm here to answer
questions we interviewed the suspect he
continued to fight our detectives
through the night several times he had
to be chained had to be hobble
restrained you remain violent with this
through the night he never told us why
he did this we know at three locations
he robbed people for cash we don't know
if that the motive behind this was
purely for robbery but there was no
indication that this was a hate crime we
just know this was a random act of
violence
and the guy Unleashed evil across our
two counties I don't know his exact
release date we're working on that
timeline right now but I know he has a
violent past he has a gang associations
and we're working on his criminal
history right now
that's not what she said was we
responded the burglary call that didn't
happen that call was still pending we
arrived on scene after we received the
phone call for the two homicides when we
were right down senior realized that the
earlier burglary calls were related to
the homicide
as things were happening it was so
dynamic it was so rapid with all these
violent crimes happening across Garden
Grove we had to pull detectives who were
also already working a homicide
they had to leave their desk suit up and
head out to the field to assist our
officers with all these different crime
scenes Michelle I don't have that
information right now we're gonna dive
into his criminal history and once we
get a full picture of everything that
happened we'll look into that yes thank
you David Valentin Chief of Police
Santana before I answer that question or
any others I also on behalf of the city
of Santa Ana want to extend our
condolences to the innocent victims
involved here all four of them not
involved directly in any criminal
activity just targeted by this vicious
suspect in this case who's in custody I
want to also thank the mayor the City
Council the police chief everybody
that's here with us jointly supporting
both of our communities and we will work
through this investigation jointly so
that's important another couple of
pieces that weren't covered this was a
sole individual attacker we don't have
any information to this point to
indicate that he was part of a broader
coordinated effort one suspect in
custody committing all of these vicious
crimes so that's important it's
important to note that and also to the
community and everybody who is listening
here that we're not looking for anyone
else at this point in terms of the
question on point we are looking into
the full background of the suspect that
we have in custody under the custody of
Garden Grove police department he the
suspect does have a sibling who was
killed in an incident in Santana yes
I know recently we were out at the
complex to deal with the suspect over a
child custody issue he was having with
his ex-wife there was some type of where
he took the child under because the
child was under monitoring monitoring
visits and he left with the child so we
went there to investigate that as far as
any other incidents involving the
suspect I don't have that right now as
far as your question about the table
being taken from our victim's residence
there was a table that was taken and
there was evidence that was recovered
and our suspects apartment
linking him to the burglary we know that
one of our victims had a sword or a
knife collection that was stolen we
don't know at this point if those swords
are knives were actually used in these
attacks today or yesterday
as far as his uh status being under the
influence of drugs I'm not aware that
but our forensics people do take blood
and photographs and they're gonna look
into that these photos to my left are
actual booking photos for a suspect so
he's been described as having numerous
tattoos by different victims as you can
see in the photos he has tattoos his
clothing description that he had on was
described by the numerous victims
there's a video of him being taken to
custody at the sudden 11:00 store
wearing the same clothing that was
described at all our crime scenes
I don't have an indication that he was
but we do take blood from our suspect
and that will be determined through the
crime lab the Mercedes is registered to
him and it's registered to that it
seemed apartment complex where there's
the first two murders took place
so the security guard was working at the
store for security purposes he was
inside he was followed by our suspect
you can see and different videos as the
security guard made his rounds in the
store the security guard was attacked by
our suspect and after being attacked and
taking down the ground stabbed numerous
times he was disarmed after that he'd
left the store where our detectives took
him to custody the parking lot the two
victims who died at the apartment
complex were roommates
the securio Caucasian male was the
lessor of the apartment and the other
male Hispanic that died at the scene we
had not identified him yet he was a
winter at the same apartment well from
the robbery victims to our oldest victim
it goes from 25 all the way up to 64
years old so we have different ages to
my right there's a timeline of all the
crimes and the ages of our victims at
the different locations
so obviously the police agencies haven't
finished their work but we're well aware
of this the district attorney mr.
Spitzer happens to be on vacation but
those decisions he's in touch with us he
has been this morning this gentleman
certainly has made himself a candidate
and those decisions aren't going to be
made until we actually file which will
be as early as tomorrow morning and
certainly will put out a full press
release when that happens but you know
this gentleman has known at this point
to have killed four people so he
certainly made himself eligible so we
couldn't hear yes why he was originally
released you I assume you're all aware
the the status of the law in California
is to continually pursue earlier an
earlier release of people incarcerated
and to continually D scheduled serious
crimes to more minor offenses and so you
know I think the struggle that you heard
from the opening remarks hear from the
chief is it's it's hard for a lot of us
to understand how this could be possible
but but the pendulum has swung in
California to the extent that this
person I think by most reasonable
standards shouldn't have been released
but the status of the law was he was
eligible
so I have seen his rap sheet this
morning I apologize I didn't commit it
to memory and I I don't it's obviously
all public record I don't know if she
called just got that chief
so he was convicted for possession of
methamphetamine for sales while armed
with an assault rifle
city in the
I know at one point the suspects mother
was living at the apartment she had
called us awhile back asking how she
could get rid of her son through the
eviction process that information was
given to her we have not reached out to
the mother and have not received any
statements from her concerning this
investigation the male victim at the gas
station is a 44 year old male Hispanic
he's undergone some surgeries trying to
reattach his nose to his face but he's
expected to survive
the female victim of the video I'll
release later on she's gone through some
surgeries I was told at one point when
he stabbed the victim the knife nearly
missed her heart so she's going to be in
the hospital for some time till she
recuperates from her injuries but she is
going to survive
they both are Orange County residents
yes the witnesses we talked to said
there was nothing in the suspect was
saying to our victims he just savagely
attacked these people and for some
reason it was fully unprovoked the
subway incident the guy was stabbed he
was not employee he was a customer that
was stabbed there and that
investigations be conducted by Santana
PD but there was nothing that was said
that we've learned from that which
person
yeah I haven't heard that that's being
handled by Santana PD investigators but
I know he was either inside the business
or just right outside the business where
I know at one point talking to her
detectives our suspect was covered in
blood from these different crimes and at
one point he told winter investigators
that that was not blood it was tomato
juice that he had on him so again the
suspect remained violent with us he
struggled with her officers being taken
into custody back here at the police
department he continued to struggle with
her officers at one point he was
handcuffed he slipped his handcuffs and
put into the front so he remained
combated the entire time he was here I'm
not aware of that so I just know he's a
violent offender
yeah it's my understanding it was not an
officer-involved shooting the homicide
in our city yes quick clarification
7-eleven says that this security card
was not employed by the store lady next
door said he wasn't and you're saying he
was I just want to clarify I'm just be
informed that he was not employed by
this store so that I misspoke on that
he's just a customer in from that's what
I'm learning just now right outside the
stores what I was told so the video of
the attack I'm gonna I'm still editing
it I'm trying to blur out our victim to
protect her but I still want to show how
savagely this attack was I'm going to
Dropbox it to the media with the Dropbox
link and you guys should receive that
probably within an hour
he's 33 years old I don't have his date
of birth with me right now and he had
questions again I don't want to thank
the public and for tuning in and listen
to us and I want to thank the media for
being here to help us get this word out
we got to stop these acts of violence in
Garden Grove Santana and across the
United States and we need the help with
the public to help us do this so thank
you very much
our suspect
he lives in Garden Grove he lived at the
apartment complex with homicides his
date of birth is to 6 1986 to 686 your
baby's name again
Zachary Castaneda thank you I don't know
where he was originally from za c h8 our
wives a curry and Castaneda CAS T a and
D D a